I've spent the past seven years
traveling the world perfecting my craft
you see I'm something of a magician
inventor and chocolate maker so quiet up
and listen down nope scratch that
reverse it
Mr wankara can say you're a man a great
engineering what are you doing
I'm making chocolate of course how do
you like dark white nutty absolutely
insane many people have come here to
sell chocolate they've all been crushed
by the chocolate cartel you can't get a
shop without selling chocolate and you
can't sell chocolate without a shop
no daydreaming what are we gonna do
Willie
huh
double huh depends on paper uh-huh I got
an idea
I know things haven't been easy for you
they're gonna get better you promise I
Pinky Promise that's the most solemn bow
there is where do we start
where is this it's just cool what's
happening oh that's a chocolate that
makes you fly let's find out shall we
who's forever
see here just a small group of people
defining the laws of gravity
ladies and gentlemen of the gallery
Gourmet
my name is Willy Wonka
he's good too good
yeah pretty sure I've gained about 150
pounds in the last two weeks you could
change her life Mr auger change all
their lives
every good thing in this world started
with a dream
Here We Go Mama
mark my words this is gonna be the
greatest chocolate shop
ever seen
you're the funny little man who's been
following me I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size foreign